mais le sang
au québec
je reçois bien
je ne reçois plus
ok bien reçu donc je traduis comme si je
traduisais la vingtaine
bien sûr alors tenten c'est parti
mesdames et messieurs bonjour nous
accueillons aujourd'hui on n'a pas la
boxe suite à la reconnaissance par là
j'entends du mil suite à la
reconnaissance par vladimir poutine des
républiques populaires de donetsk et de
lougansk cette reconnaissance de ces
républiques autoproclamées selon les
pays occidentaux a suscité l'indignation
et le déclenchement de sanctions déjà
annoncé depuis longtemps contre la
russie entre autres sanctions la
suspension de l'autorisation du gazoduc
north stream ii qui courent en tout cas
qui était censé acheminer du gaz
directement
pas de souci
je commence qui était censé acheminer du
gaz directement depuis la russie jusqu'à
l'allemagne en passant par la mer
baltique
ce gazoduc que permettait d'éviter les
pays craignent un polonais etc et
faisait de lanaye le carrefour
énergétique de l'europe
ce gazoduc était depuis longtemps soumis
à polémique merci
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs
chers jean-yves
nous nous voyons quasiment tous les
jours c'est ainsi à paris à bruxelles à
munich
cela serait un bon signe dans cette
période c'est une bonne chose de nous
rencontrer mais malheureusement il ne
s'agit pas de raison je suis 5
ta venue aujourd'hui à berlin est
d'autant plus d'estimé
tu as pris part à la réunion de notre
nouveau conseil des ministres de ce
nouveau gouvernement allemand est ainsi
tu as montré à quel point l'amitié et la
coopération entre l'allemagne et la
france et est étroite
ces rencontres régulières qui ont
commencé en 2019
montre que nous sommes des pays voisins
qui ne peuvent reconstruire un avenir qu
ensemble
et nous devons travailler de concert
dans l'avenir cher jean yves je souhaite
donc de remercier
pour tout le travail est
incessant pour l'amitié franco allemande
dans les actes comme dans les paroles
dans les périodes heureuses comme dans
les périodes difficiles ne pouvons nous
faire confiance et aujourd'hui c'est
très précieux et c'est également loin
d'être évident
notre coopération est d'autant plus
importante que en tant qu'européens nous
sommes des partenaires
important dans le cadre de la crise en
russie et nous devons mettre à l'épreuve
le gouvernement russe
superbement
veut
gagner aux dépens de ses voisins
au mépris total du droit et de l'ordre
et de la paix
et il reste complètement indifférent au
sort des personnes concernées des deux
côtés
et maquilleurs des semaines et des mois
à passer nous avons averti le
gouvernement russe des conséquences de
ses actions
nous sommes restés dans une optique de
discussions bilatérales mais également
au sein de l'union européenne de l'otan
du g7 de l'oas et eux et dans tous les
autres canaux de discussion
cette coopération étroite avec nos
partenaires
européenne a imposé à décider d'un train
de sanctions fermes
les entreprises les banques et les
individus falette qui
sous tend une main qui ont pris part à
cette attaque contre la souveraineté
ukraine
la russie
n'aura plus l'accès au marché de nos
pays et ces sanctions peuvent encore
être renforcée
il était également important pour le
gouvernement de montrer au niveau
national que nous nous engageons pour
une ukraine libre souveraine et
démocrates nous avons tous pris des
décisions la liberté et la paix
en europe n'ont pas de prix c'est
pourquoi nous avons décidé de suspendre
l'autorisation
d'un stream 2 vous connaissez déjà mon
opposition à son projet il était genk
d'autant plus important pour moi et pour
nous
au vu du changement de paradigme de
montrer que les actions de la russie
aurait des conséquences
et
agir en fonction de cela et mme jean
yves le drian je suis gentil vous savez
la présidence de la france et votre moto
et de renforcer la souveraineté
européenne
vous avez montré que pour vous il ne
s'agit pas que de moi mais également des
rédactions
et je veux je te remercie donc du fond
du coeur merci beaucoup
nous voyons effectivement tous les jours
et c'est un plaisir renouvelé
je suis ravi d'être ici auprès de toi à
berlin
est très honoré d'être le premier membre
du gouvernement français à participer un
conseil des ministres du nouveau
gouvernement allemand et tu l'a rappelé
ce principe et est inscrit dans le
traité dès que ça s'appelle
et j'ai eu l'honneur d'être aussi le
premier ministre français a appliqué ce
principe du traité des chapelles puisque
j'ai assisté conseil des ministes de
l'allemagne au mois de mars 2019 mais là
cette
participation est particulièrement
significative
dans un contexte de gravité sur lequel
je vais revenir mais aussi dans un
contexte où l'allemagne préside le g7
tu as manifestées hier cette présidence
en réunissant par vision à paris les
ministres affaires étrangères du g 7 et
la france préside l'union européenne et
nous devons agir de concert dans ces
deux présidents c'est ce que nous
faisons et je vais à dire d'un des
messieurs que nous ne connaissions pas
avant et au fur à mesure de ses
rencontres je tiens de le dire
publiquement
nous avons établi
non seulement une relation de confiance
très forte et aussi une relation
d'amitié je crois et je crois qu'ils
étaient à berlin qu'il fallait se le
dire
tu dois dire aussi que tout cela
s'inscrit dans une détermination
personnelle que j'ai depuis très
longtemps
du renforcement
de l'axé franco allemand et c'est
d'autant plus important maintenant que
nous allons vers le 66 soit 60e
anniversaire du traité de l'elysée qui
aura lieu l'année prochaine mais déjà
cette année le soixantième anniversaire
de la rencontre de gaulle adenauer le 8
juillet 2022 et puis le 60e anniversaire
du discours du général de gaulle à la
jeunesse allemande à ludwigsburg en
septembre 62 tout ça c'est notre
histoire mais c'est aussi notre force
nous nous avons pu
au cours de ce conseil
des ministres abordée et la question de
l'ukraine et de la russie la question du
mali et puis le déroulé de la présidence
française de l'union européenne en
particulier après le premier forum indo
pacifique que nous avons organisée à
paris hier et auxquels elle a participé
et nous avons pu aussi constater sur ces
trois sujets les grandes convergences de
vue que nous avions ce qui n'était pas
une surprise mais il convient de se
redire régulièrement pour continuer à
avancer ensemble dans cette convergence
devrait revenir simplement sur un point
dans mon propos introductif concernant
la situation en ukraine et en russie
pour souligner aussi notre convergence
et souligner les quatre principes sur
lesquels je crois nous sommes en phase
il ya d'abord un principe de fermeté
le président poutine a rompu avec le
droit international
le
président poutine dans son discours a
d'une certaine manière
déclaré la négation de l'ukraine comme
pays souverain
nous sommes en phase de révisionnisme
pour retrouver des espaces anciens en
réinventant l'histoire
et puis
manifestement
la russie va le président poutine
n'honore pas la signature de la russie
ne répond pas la signature de la russie
que ce soit signature de la russie sur
la charte de paris re
confortant un axe de stabilité l'anact
de stabilité et
donnant les garanties de sécurité en
europe
ne répond pas la signature de la russie
en
renonçant aux accords de minsk et d'une
manière générale ils ne répondent pas
aux engagements qu'il prend
ni en public ni en privé que ce soit à
l'égard du présent macro et les gars du
champ ces échelles ce
fermeté
nous en avons fait preuve
nous avons fait preuve dans l'unité
c'est le deuxième principe
et c'est dans la fermeté dans l'unité
l'unité des 27
qui s'est manifesté hier à paris par un
accord unanime sur le paquet de
sanctions que viens d'évoquer anna lena
et unité aussi au delà puisque
nos alliés sont aussi dans la
convergence des options que nous avons
pu prendre hier
fermeté unités mais solidarité avec
l'ukraine que ce soit la solidarité
politique affichée la solidarité
financière la soleil de la solidarité
de toutes les manières que nous pouvons
mobiliser peau pour ce faire et puis en
gardant quatrième principe l'esprit du
dialogue parce que
nous sommes tous très attachés à ce que
la diplomatie l'emportent sur la guerre
mais encore faut-il pour dialoguer être
deux
et on ne peut pas se substituer à
l'autre partie nous sommes sur ces
quatre principes et nous les déclinant
dans les différents lieux et les
différentes instances nous sommes amenés
à intervenir je crois que la
fermeté des positions que nous avons
prises la rapidité des sanctions que
nous avons initié pas ce que vont
s'appliquer dès maintenant dès
aujourd'hui en moins en moins de 24
heures entre la déclaration du président
poutine et la décision européenne une
année il ya eu 20 heures sur un premier
paquet de sanctions c'est un premier
paquet de sanctions
tout cela fait que dans la situation
grave dans laquelle nous sommes nous
confortons nos convergences et la force
de notre partenariat voilà ce que je
voulais dire mon introduction
l'application de la
question concernant l'ukraine partagez
vous le point de vue de votre collègue
britannique qui estime hautement
probable que monsieur poutine veille à
envahir totalement l'ukraine et même
prendre kiev
je suis pas là dans la tête de monsieur
poutine
ce qui est certain c'est que il y a une
forme d'accumulation
de gestion de la tension
de la confusion de l'ambiguïté et de la
manipulation
et le président poutine est un grand
artiste de la déclinaison parallèle de
ces quatre thèmes
mais bien évidemment quand on a cent
quarante mille militaires
aux frontières de l'ukraine
mobilisés
il y avait eu des déclarations de
retrait
poste manoeuvre et nous ne constatons
pas
tout est possible y compris le pire
ce qui est sans doute le plus
préoccupant dans l'immédiateté
c'est le fait que les discours porte
sur la totalité de l'oblast du nom basse
or les républiques autoproclamées
ne concerne mais nous concerne
aujourd'hui qu'une partie dont kylie a
menacé un risque de ce côté là
je dis simplement tout est possible même
le pire d'où la nécessité de renforcer
notre détermination pour le premier
paquet de sanctions et les paquets de
sanctions à venir
pour ce show président personnes puis
voir ce qui se passe dans la tête
72 dernières heures nous avons bien vu
que tous les scénarios étaient possibles
est
empêché le
souveraineté et droit des codes et de
pouvoir vivre en liberté dans leur
propre pays et nous voulons défendre
cela via tous les canaux
il ya différents scénarios
différentes formes selon lesquelles on
pourrait déstabiliser l'ukraine
et nous l'avons dit au cours de ce
discours nous allons garantir le droit à
la liberté et à la paix pour les
ukrainiens
nous préparions longtemps et nous
voulons être clairs sur ce point
nous défendrons l'ukraine
question
monsieur le ministre vous avez évoqué
des sanctions vous avez également
mentionné que il y aurait des étapes à
suivre
pensez vous que ces sanctions pourrait
infléchir
la proche de vladimir poutine vis-à-vis
de l'ukraine
vous avez annulées ne rencontre avec
monsieur lavrov vendredi
quelles sont les perspectives d'après
vous du format normandie après ces
actions de vladimir poutine merci
beaucoup
mais plus qu'aux petits
sketches de sanction il s'agit d'une
part de la sécurité de l'ukraine doit
plus avoir dit ce qu'elle a dit est
également et je les dis à dominique
de l'ordre international art is a rose
la crise entre la crise russe le maire
de port à changer
souhaitons montrer que ce qui est arrivé
au cours des dernières heures
ses traités de danse marie centrale à
maintenir le droit à la paix avec ses
voisins
c'est comme menace je mets du maire
poutine
avec un seuil sanction très rapide des
chaussettes également encore une fois le
soulier comme l'a dit mon collègue
français ces sanctions étaient très
rapides ou car il était très important
d'agir de manière rapide et coordonnée
avec nos partenaires afin de montrer que
nous n'acceptons pas du tout mais ces
actions
et effectivement il ya d'autres mesures
possibles
c'est un train graduée de aux sanctions
ces tirs la première étape a montré que
nous n'acceptons pas la situation mais
nous avons toujours été très clair
prendre toutes les mesures dures si cela
s'avère nécessaire
s'agissant de la question pour le format
normandie je l' ai déjà dit
s'agissant du format d'euros 10 h
descente du traité de lézignan disque
ce traité et ce format a été détruit
littéralement
le holisme le président l'a dit hier
poutine tu as fait ça mais il doit
toujours laissé une porte ouverte au
dialogue et vouloir empêcher la gamme
première nous voulons empêcher la guerre
ensemble
et nous nous sommes entretenu au
téléphone avec notre collègue russe
sergueï lavrov
c est à vous c'est vous qui avez le
pouvoir de revenir un stade des
négociations
et nous réagirons aux mesures que prend
la russie
les sanctions
ce sont des sanctions sérieuses le
premier paquet de sanctions est un
paquet de sanctions sérieux et ce qui va
faire mal pour ce qui est bon les subir
donc nous avons constaté leur
leur réaction à la mise en oeuvre des
sanctions c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
qu'elle soit forte et rapide donc c'est
immédiat compris sur la désignation d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont les
responsables des décisions qui ont été
prises je pense aux particuliers aux
députés de la douma ça va commencer
difficile fois des sanctions ils doivent
s'appliquer elles seront elles seront
fermées douloureuse dans le premier
paquet et ensuite il y aura d'autres
paquets
sur le format normandie ce format existe
toujours nous n'y renoncerons pas il ya
là un espace de discussion qui
existaient et qui doit continuer à être
ouvert pour que nous puissions avancer
sur le règlement pacifique de la crise
ukrainienne
c'est le brisant pauline qui remet en
cause les fondamentaux
il y avait avant les principes et une
méthode des principes c'était les
accords de minsk la méthode c'était le
format normandie la méthode reste il
faut revenir aux principes
de
ce ministre sam hamad ministre bonjour
concernant la crise russe on a vu ces
deux semaines un président russe capable
de dire du jour au lendemain la russie
ne veut pas la guerre est pratiquement
une semaine après des troupes russes
dans le donbass
face à finalement ces personnalités qui
vous l'avez dit monsieur ministre peut
manier l'ambiguïté pour la manipulation
mais en même temps déclare qu'on ne peut
pas la guerre ma question principale
c'est ce que vous voyez vous madame
verbaux que vous monsieur le ministre le
drian encore d'amples admire poutine un
partenaire de discussion crédible fiable
amener à la table des négociations fugue
pour le moment ça a l'air quand même des
trains quadro ans qu à droite un coup à
gauche je remercie
on le connaît un
je pense que finalement
à ce moment de l'histoire le présent
macron est sans doute celui qui s'est le
plus donc peut être capable le président
poutine
ça donnait il avait bien commencé le
président macron
les élections en rangs législation
présidentielle de 2017 on sait comment
elles ont pu faire l'objet de
manipulations venus de russie
etc le président m'a conquis lui même a
dit au président poutine a pas à
versailles en juillet 2010 cette croix
bien je ne suis pas dupe de ce que tu as
fait
donc
pense composants de la république à une
certaine habitude de la pratique du
président poutine mais il est certain
qu'il fallait qu'il faut toujours
essayer jusqu'au bout d'éviter une
solution de confrontation et de
permettre
l'accès à la diplomatie c'est ce à quoi
s'est employée et le président de la
république et le chancelier de dans les
jours qui précèdent qui viennent de
s'écouler
sans aboutir
mais cette main tendue reste toujours la
passe rien n'est pire que l'affrontement
guerrier
alors après
quand et comment faut-il croire sur
parole le président poutine
je ne sais pas si quelqu'un le sait
ça n'empêche pas pour nous l'apprécions
l'exigence la fermeté
et le combat pour éviter que une
solution guerrière nous impose
c'est les mêmes principes unités fermeté
solidarité dialogue
j'en ai acheté
aux cycliques et se trouve en abondance
également
s'agissant
que lorsque quelqu'un dit toujours
quelque chose et fait le contraire une
semaine plus tard on peut en déduire la
réalité et la vérité c'est à dire que la
personne et le contrat dit
cela mène à des attaques contre le droit
international
vit bien et il faut donc que nos fans
parler de la façon dont on peut éviter
une guerre nomade peu de préserver la
paix et cela il un collègue l'a bien
montré ému à chaque fois nous l'avons
souligné la semaine dernière
il faut le dire nous voulons garantir
l'acheter
les membres de l'otan sont de notre côté
je
souhaite remercier la présidence
française de l'union belge et le
principe d'un cidre des affaires
étrangères hier malgré la situation que
nous créons ce malgré la réunion
informelle des ministres des affaires
étrangères
nous sommes
entretenu avec nos partenaires
la région de l'inde au pacifique ce qui
montre donc que la communauté
internationale
il veut pas tolérer cette violation du
droit international
il a réussi sept isolé et
l'avons encore montré dans notre
discours il coûte
une
stratégie à moyen ou à la cour valable
de s'isoler complètement du reste du
monde
action
contre la liberté et la paix dans un
état voisin doivent cesser afin que la
russie puisse
rejoindre la communauté internationale
il est question pour vous deux
messieurs les techniques tout en face ne
m'intéresse
comment va-t-elle se dérouler à l'avenir
merci beaucoup
expriment vérité cette édition est
extrêmement
l'alpha et l'oméga de l'action
internationale
est important d information
nous permet de choisir à une machine me
retrouver dans les explications des
justifications pour
des troupes russes allaient
trouver la
passe et
ça fait mal
expliqué de ma 46e cessez le feu et
c'est d'autant plus important en face à
une telle destination
il est important de garantir la sécurité
et nous sommes des
européens pour discuter de son
succès
qu'il y à des questions de droit
il est en tout cas très important
fille le fils que
ça change et qui se passe dans cette
région
où vivent beaucoup de familles beaucoup
de personnes des jeunes des personnes
âgées nous ne devons pas détourner les
yeux
totalement d'accord avec les propos de
d'anna lena
il faut que nous ayons un outil
d'observation indépendant
le préserver
et validé par son existence la justesse
de ses observations
donc c'est un point central et j'ai tout
à fait le même avis qu anna lena sur le
sur ce sujet
touche à sa fin merci beaucoup pour
votre participation merci beaucoup